islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
that's a gift from me too
you can read it if you have any
questions about it
now or if you're if you don't want to
make it away
you guys need to go would you like to
read my passage
oh you know actually you know why don't
we open it somewhere okay let's just see
what it says
and punch me out there
already
any verses
okay so
he said my lord prison is more
more to my liking than that to which
they invite me and if you do not avert
from me their plan i might incline
towards them and thus be of the ignorant
so his lord responded to him and averted
from him their plan and indeed he is all
here and going over so this is uh
so there's prophet yusuf joseph
yeah and so for example
a lot of women
so here there's actually um there was
there was the ruler there was a pharaoh
and there was this minister
and
his minister when he was a child adopted
him adopted him
um and when he did that as he grew older
the minister's wife kind of fell in love
with him and he was actually calling him
to have sex with him
and he's a prophet of god
the thing is he himself
um
was basically because he's a prophet of
god he didn't want that so basically he
was saying here he's praying to god oh
god protecting me from these women
because they are calling me to something
that i fear that it isn't by your mercy
i might incline to it okay yeah so
obviously he's not but he just fears for
himself so
he was imprisoned in the story
and he prefers to be in prison
then be out where these women are
hunting him down
yeah
so
this is
but you see as muslims and muslim men
we are told to honor people and
especially women as well what's your
name sister my name's talia
yeah that's a very unique name so this
is italia what we're seeing is that the
reason i refer to as a sister is because
i don't want you to think that i am
flirting with you in any way shape or
form because sometimes what happens is
sadly
if we see the opposite gender yeah yeah
it doesn't matter how they dress
up
we have to know our cases the reason
being is because we don't want to look
at them as sexual objects they are human
beings
so that's the reason why for example
it's so important like you said that in
today's time that's every man's dream
yeah but to him i prefer to
but the point is this the default
position is that we should have respect
to every woman and that even like
if if we see a woman dressed in
inappropriate know whatever that we're
talking about and look away that's out
of respect but today's time another
woman will see that as offensive why is
he not looking at me am i ugly
but that's sad that shouldn't be the
case a lot of people
claim that
claim that as muslims or islam um
is against women's rights or et cetera
but islam is the only religion that is
there to honor a woman
in the right way because for example um
for example
sorry yeah so for example one of the
things is that
when
for example dating we don't believe in
dating because we believe i believe
dating is the biggest thought
ever for women because you've got a man
that you're in a relationship with you
call him your boyfriend
you have no idea what he wants from you
but you are getting this relationship
with the hopes that
with a woman for you obviously
you you might be thinking okay i love
him i want to play the rest of my life
with him but to him it's just like i
want sex well you don't know that so
because you don't know that you invest
yourself in there emotionally and in
different ways as well and then after
that you're heartbroken or used so what
islam does is in order to protect the
woman islam says that there is no dating
if for example
i am interested in an individual
i have to go and speak to her dad
that's the person
cause number one because that's her
guardian
yeah so i need to go and speak to her
father and ask him is it like a respect
thing
some people see it as possession but
what we see is as i'm it's my daughter
yeah and i want to protect my daughter
because there are men out there who's
going to use and abuse them yeah so the
thing is here even though our society
has made an abnormal thing yeah as i go
i'm woman i'm an independent yes yes but
the point is this for example that your
parent or like your dad or your brother
is there to protect you because they're
a man and they know how a man is yeah so
me personally i was raised by a single
partner okay so you know my mum had me
quite a young age and um so i don't know
my little father personally so i feel
that um you know my mom has done really
quite a good job me and myself
it gives me a nice reminder that it's
not specific like you said to one gender
you know it's very much you know
yeah again diverse yeah
is that these procedures are put in
place to protect the well-being of the
woman so she's not emotionally
manipulated and given false promises and
then used and and because what happens
is you see a lot of women who have been
in a relationship and then it doesn't
work out now in your mind you're
thinking okay i'll go into this
relationship and he was my boyfriend but
in his mind he was there for you just
for one thing and this reoccurring
pattern puts you in an insecure position
it would be wrong of me to assume that a
gentleman
exactly but not everyone is like you
that's the thing because you're
good-hearted you think everyone is like
you but he's not
they're not but that's the reason why
islam stipulated that if an individual
is interested in you you should speak to
your dad number one number two that when
you are getting to know him there's a
chaperone
so this is a chaperone that will be
there in the dating process for you to
get to know each other
now this might be seen a bit like
chaperone hovering over me but the point
is this it is there once again because
if a man is after the wrong thing he
knows your brother or your mother or
your father is there and he's going to
be thinking twice because he's going to
cover that's the consequences if i do
something wrong that's point number two
number three if it comes to the point
where marriage is going to happen then
you have a right to dowry so the diary
is anything you like gold money uh you
can say look i want you to buy me a car
so that's very materialistic thing it is
but the point here is it's your security
because if a man has the intentions of
wanting you for one thing even though
he's met your dad and he doesn't care
about that now financially he knows hold
in a second she's asking for gold it
doesn't make you a gold digger i don't
believe this concept it is your right to
have something because it's your
security if he decides to leave you that
you have something to hold on to because
a lot of guys here in today's age
they're called deadbeat that's you know
they go and sleep around leave and
disappear and you're left in a financial
insecurity so that is your security so
what you ask for also prevents him from
being after you for the wrong things
because if you come and say i want 5
thousand pounds which is your right
nobody can ever call you gold digger
that is your right we believe in islam
that is your security so i know that
okay i've spoken to the father yes i've
got to know a few days and chaperone is
there i'm okay with that she wants
something which if i really love her and
i want to spend the rest of my life i
have no problem paying five thousand
dollars i'm so sorry if i love you and i
want to be with you i'm gonna pay that
five thousand pounds now then given that
then it's the what the marriage uh the
nikkei the marriage now with the
marriage in a relationship
sometimes it's something that is hidden
but with a marriage it's something that
should be announced to the people i am
marrying this woman yeah so it's not
hidden i really like that it's exactly i
believe that a lot more people should be
open to
exactly just be like look
i
because now once you're married you have
rights in marriage so he has a right to
provide for you not sharing the rent you
don't pay a single penny on the rent
really yes you don't see a single
pending on the shopping he has to
provide but this is very interesting
because the reason why this is
stipulated
with my sister's name yeah i'm so sorry
are you okay
so i'm so sorry we're nearly done
her name is leila
yeah
is it she muslim
muslims
okay no problem
do you mind me asking um how it is on
the flip side with men as well you know
how
in terms
you know get a relationship with a lady
you want to go meet their family and
stuff
so what about a gentleman's perspective
you know
like for example i have my mother as my
protector okay
a man doesn't need a guardian
so a man in that perspective doesn't
need a guardian so a man can choose to
get married without
his parents yeah but then again the
reason might be because of that is
because most of the times men have the
power and the concept if you're in a
relationship he can try to blackmail you
he can try to force himself on you he
can do all kinds of things yeah that's
the reason why you require a guardian
because in the sense not that look i
believe women are emotionally very
strong we are physically strong but
women are emotionally very strong that's
why we have highest suicide rates with
men yeah it is it's very very powerful
exactly and single single mothers a lot
of scholars in islam they had single
mothers that like you know we and i
believe single mothers i praise them a
lot because they are like mother and
father if you play like if you look at
it they do an immense amazing job you
know i'm sure your mother has to bring
up childhood like yourself so the thing
is here sister is that that's the reason
why i stipulated for a woman because a
woman can be overpowered yeah in
different ways you know there's revenge
porn and all this kind of stuff so
that's the reason why a guardian is
required for a woman not because she is
not
not capable in certain intellectual
capacity in that way but it's there to
protect you because there are men out
there that can abuse you we know a lot
of people again when we're getting sex
trafficking you know why because this
man has this and if you don't do that
i'm gonna do you give him trying to say
it's there to protect you i don't really
want to see
um a gentleman as a predator though you
know
it would be wrong no no he shouldn't i
don't think the default position for us
is to feel like that but then we have a
reality to deal with yeah we had for
example
yes for example yeah these cases happen
and it's in reality even though we don't
want to see it like that and we
shouldn't for example i don't think when
you look at me you're like a sexual
predator you assume the best which is
good
exactly that is good but also it is your
right to protect yourself because
putting your guards down for example
could cost
other things to happen so islam is
prevention is better than cure so it's
called stipulations in place to protect
the woman and her rights
yes and not to be it used to be cared
for you know but some people say this
and be like oh islam makes a woman seem
as though she can't know yeah
that's the reason why the guardianship
from your dad goes to your husband
because now it's a trans now like we're
living let's say
you marry someone and you're living
together he's your god and that's why i
said he has to pay for the rent he has
to provide for you you can work if you
like as well but you are in constant
maintenance yeah yeah and that is better
a lot of people like oh no like i'm a
feminist and this that i believe there
was a study done over 100 000 people in
a matter of 25 years they found out that
women are less happier in the workplace
you know like and i'm not saying
necessarily this doesn't mean they
shouldn't work but what we're seeing is
for example this this movement of you
know you have women who are in the
business workplace 30 40 no kids and
they hit a rock and they hit rock bottom
and they're like well what now i have a
family i'm an age where i don't if i can
have kids so what we're seeing is you
can work but it is your husband's duty
to provide and maintain that's why
men are the maintainers and protectors
of women so if i'm walking with my wife
and somebody pulls a knife out i'm not
going to say darling
if a war happens we have to go and
protect so we are there but this should
be honored it shouldn't be seen as you
know because we're trying to take care
of women that's what i'm trying to point
out that how it's done yeah and
and it's really nice and respectful in
terms of hijab and as well and i
understand that it's not necessarily
something you have to wear
yeah there's difference but you don't
have to do it
you know let's check up on layla
are you okay
you know i find it really lovely that um
that's
[Music]
can i give you a hug
we don't have an agenda
even in the workplace making gestures of
touching the knee or this guy etc islam
is prevention thank you i'm trying to
say yeah i really love you it's not
really much
too much
you know i really wanna
islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes a quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can